I found this on
[Music]
[Music]
even you know after eight years I still
never show up to start these things okay
so this is penny this is um so you are a
youtuber under student at Exeter so what
do you what do you study in what's your
channel um so I study psychology and I
my channel is called Cheney up with this
girl did you be down there really I
guess my first question is with regards
to the whole leak of the whatsapp
screenshots does this surprise you like
does the the views of extra students
being expressed does that surprise you
just how does that fit in with your
personal experience I don't think it
surprised me because if you've seen the
news and if you've been an exerciser
been a lot of incidents in the past so
say when the Nazi sign was carved in
that this is a bit grim yeah that's
strange
and when a student put up a theme that
said rights for white outside the door
things like that have happened before
and I've had friends white people who
like stood up to those people and said
you know it's just a joke and to me it
felt like those racist views are
untouchable and like there was no form
punishment for that so it didn't
surprise me that things like that
continue to happen so do you think then
you notice of that time for that
instance there wasn't a kind of
appropriate punishment that if you feel
like people it didn't really change
anything do you think the university is
taking steps this time if not yeah what
should they be doing well I think this
time it's been better in the way that
the unist
spoken out about it because Mohamed
didn't notice any formal statement on
the Twitter Facebook and this time
they've they put the Twitter out they
because they suspended the students yeah
and there's an investigation yeah
there's an investigation going on
um but I think the Uni could do better
than that
okay um because this needs to be a lot
there needs to be a lot of education to
students overall about the sole issue
and it hasn't been done effectively so
previously in Exeter there was this
campaign called never okay and the
poster of the pledge was vandalized with
like racist comments and sexist comments
but the Uni didn't address that and lied
about it and just hid it away and it
undermined the meaning of the campaign
in it yeah sort of covering for people
who make those claims mm-hmm
I think it was like little things like
this that led to this kind of thing yeah
okay um so do you think then that there
is not necessarily the institution
itself is racist but do you think
there's a racism problem next evening I
just think like if you look at those
statistics excel has not got like like I
guess the lowest be Amin yeah yeah it's
got really low BME percentage and
because they're so many white people
they they don't necessarily have the
experience of the AME students and yeah
they may not be socially aware enough of
the problems yeah you can be
subconsciously contributing to a culture
of not necessarily oppression but like
you know it's all the little things that
you don't pick up as a white person yeah
yeah and then do you think next of it
has it more of a problem that is this a
unit is this a uky problem is it
particularly bad a next test
um because I haven't had experience in
the universe yeah I can't really
tallip it's like a um like a UK by the
problem yeah but I think it's definitely
a problem in Exeter that needs
addressing this is about your - you've
had personal experiences have you like
this I don't know I don't know what
you've more the right word is like how
would you just it's different again is
that the problem with being a white
person I don't even know the right word
to use like you know so have you have
personal experiences I guess of being
treated differently because you are ba
me I remember I've been told I was
racist to white people because I've
refused sexual advances from a white
dude like yeah I don't know my channel
but what the [ __ ] I just feel like as it
part of my identity was erased when I'm
here because I like there are certain
things in my behavior in my personality
that don't really fit in the Asian
stereotypes and I've like I've seen
people questioning my identity as a
woman of color so feminist society they
tend to do this poetry night every year
called women of color per tree night
it's our good friend yeah I'm going
through that and I'm going to read out
my poem
and like literally they asked me like
what you women of color like are you a
woman of color in a light do I look like
to you
okay okay yeah so there is a it's not
necessarily I mean okay that's not the
student body
you know the VB students who are Exeter
do you think the institution itself is
doing anything that is inherently kind
of discriminatory or I mean is that even
a fair question Latino so this is
something that I've heard from people
hmm but the into which is the
international student yes it's a
building on campus
it's for international students and
people on into courses were discouraged
by the university to join societies so
someone told me that in
their inception they would be told oh
it's very important for you to do really
well in uni and joining societies my
this like distract you from doing work
so that's literally the opposite advice
that you'd want to give a student know
like okay you shouldn't advise a student
that sort of thing so I've been told the
Uni literally discourage people from
into yeah from joining society and that
would discourage international students
and students from vme backgrounds to
interact with white students here and
that would prevent like like that
wouldn't help the problem because like
white students would not interact with
Bamu students and they wouldn't have the
opportunity to fly yeah it's almost
segregation yeah you know okay so so the
institution itself past behaviors and
the student population has behaviors
which are basically it doesn't the the
what's that leak is almost like a new
kind of it's an outlier I imagine this
isn't like every extra student feels
this way like you know um but it's kind
of fits in with a pattern of behavior
you think yeah okay
so perhaps then the next question is
before we move on to like how we can
improve it because ultimately this is
the whole point of doing this it's like
it's one thing to raise the issue
there's another thing to try and do
something about it
do you think be any students should
apply to Exeter still like is this is
this an environment you would recommend
people to avoid initially when it first
happened I just forward oh my god if I
know any the AME students I would steer
them away from X ray immediately after
this most recent instance yeah and then
I realize it wouldn't help the problem
because it just exacerbates the
experience of like be AME student
minority here so I think be AME students
should still apply to exit if
they like the cause in it if they like
the Union yeah if they like the Union if
they like their course then by all means
the objects of her and if they come here
then it would be good to have an
initiative to like get all eme students
together and make our voice heard okay
so basically you're saying that you
would recommend if you still apply
don't don't not apply because of the AME
yeah but with the proviso that something
needs to change
yes something needs to change here okay
so what what can more can students like
me do who aren't ba me but want to help
the situation um I think the best the
first thing is to like learn more about
experience of ba ma students ask eme
students like what are the little things
but you can do to help just educate
yourself really and to be active in
activism so recently there was rally in
like just outside hall room and I think
it's important for white students to get
involved in that so that they know so
that they could you know help call out
all the racist behaviors in Exeter and
hopefully make a change cuz otherwise it
feels like racist people are untouchable
here yeah it's almost like kind of just
by remaining silent you're inherently
defending them yeah so if some if there
is um as you say like getting involved
in activism if something like that
happens if there's a cause that you can
put yourself behind don't think this
isn't my fight just you know you know
this is this is a problem if if you're
at an institution that makes people feel
uncomfortable we've got us a background
that's your problem as well yeah that's
not an institution that I want to be a
part of no so so that's something that
can be done is there anything that the
university can because that's that so
that's like an individual level is there
is there
like I suggesting if the if the guild or
the university is watching this what do
you think Smith could have I'm not going
to try and ask you for the best solution
what do you think could help
I think they should encourage like more
international students interacting with
white students so maybe stop
discouraging them to join societies yeah
that seems like a good first time yeah
and like I've seen campaigns about like
diversity in Exeter but they just need
to be done more efficiently and perhaps
more frequently throughout the year so
when you say more efficiently what do
you mean because it more frequently yeah
you know make sense but when you say
more efficiently what you mean so
instead of like hiding when the hashtag
no okay pledge was vandalized they
should have made like statements
regarding it and okay call out students
who made racist views comments on that
pledge and it shouldn't just be like
just a pleasure everyone signing and
just a couple post online it should be
like there should be more educational
say events or talks organized by actual
GME students so that it's more it's more
like a authentic view of experience of
being I mean I was just just the thought
ever had is often with those events that
are being to be any students but they
are kind of sometimes they're marketed
in a way that this is only 50 aiming
like if this if you're white this isn't
gonna be your thing so like in a way
doesn't mind of like heightened the
divide between the two because like then
be a me students have almost like their
events and then the student restless
dream profession has their events so
what's the way to get cross-pollination
of those two groups
these are just the way that it's
marketed do you think possibly yeah
but I've seen events that are marketed
really well so say the Holi festival on
campus I think it tends to be organized
by Asian society it's advertised really
well and even white my white friends are
aware of it and they seem to be really
excited about it I seem to be keen to
know more about the whole culture and
the whole Holi thing so if more events
can be marketed like that so perhaps
maybe that's a way that then guild of
the uni can get involved is that you
know it's heightening awareness of those
events it's you know it's if that's a
simple thing to do you just so yeah it's
such a simple thing to do I think it
would be such a big cause such a big
impact I mean that makes nice to meet
you certainly later cuz it's making
people where there are be any students
here you know and they are doing really
cool stuff so okay if you're listening
x2 that's that's a recommendation to
actually get but it was there anything I
should want to say I realize we've been
talking for a while but I think this
isn't this is important to include
hopefully I've included this in full and
what be a few cuts but you know what
else the floor is yours
you know what else do you think is
important to say about not just this
incident but like I guess the whole
issue of racism Exeter is there anything
else do you think's been an unsaid so
that's pretty very good question yeah
question I think like the curriculum
like things that are talked here as a
university can be made more racially
diverse okay because I've got friends
who study English literature and they
had a lecture on post colonialism it was
taught by a what a white person mean
my friends who are be AME felt that it
was not a good idea because
post-colonialism
being taught from a white perspective
it's it's not okay well one of the
things is about kind of reclaiming
national identity after the colonial
period so okay that makes sense
yeah I mean it's obviously that's
obviously subject-specific right because
in matters for example I preach I speak
for pretty much all mathematicians and
that we don't care where the math comes
from where it's for stuff like English
is inherently bound up with national
identity yeah okay
and perhaps the Uni could recommend like
reading so courses could recommend
reading from BA in the author's yep
so I think psychology has been quite
good at that
I recently biological bases of behavior
and I had to do like critical review of
one of the two papers they recommended
it both of them were written by being
the authors and I think that was really
good like bringing awareness that being
ba MEP exists and yes they are
successful
I know an argument against that that
some people make is but you know you
just want to read the best stuff the
guards were at come from but like does
that mean it's ridiculous to say the be
any authors have never produced anything
that's good like yeah there's plenty of
good to that I mean certain even is
something I actually think in maps and
the science generally like contributions
are people particularly from places like
India are massively overlooked despite
the fact that is really good often eat
historically it's really interesting as
well so it's like it's not positive
discrimination of being like or because
there be a we're gonna like put more
spotlight on it it's just like almost
removing the original prejudice that you
have for white authors if that makes
sense
yeah is that what is that one is that
right yeah okay good
check out penny there'll be a link down
there to her YouTube channel I'll put
your Twitter as well yeah why not I'll
put a Twitter as well thank you so much
for having a chance this is this is
important and I'm glad that I was able
to at least try and contribute to this
discussion so extra if you're watching
there's a whole bunch of stuff to act on
it yet so I'm conscious I don't want to
take up loads of time on Monday in this
blog but like you're remiss to not
mention that I am currently doing tech
for a performance of Handel's Messiah
University of X the chapel choir are
streaming they're trying to stream more
and more so I'm doing multiple cameras
and stuff like that I'll include a link
down in the description but yeah I mean
that's enough of Monday I'll see you
tomorrow
[Music]
okay and there is so much to do so I've
just got back in and I've been doing
some emails I am behind on this fast and
light video I'm gonna be delaying the
release of the most recent vlog so that
it doesn't kind of spoil what that's the
videos going to be about so my plan is
today to finish writing the FTL video
redraft it get it to a point where I
could film it I know already that I'm
going to be too tired later to film so
I'll film tomorrow and then it's gonna
be a case of bang bang bang trying to
trying to edit it this one will be a
much simpler edit than previous videos
there won't be as many graphics so it
should be fast to edit so I'm doing that
and I'm also doing some contract work
something else that I do pop from my own
videos and YouTube stuff is kind of like
last night where I was live streaming
for Chapel Choir I sometimes get paid to
do stuff by other people and in this
case I'm actually doing some videos for
somebody else now because that's you
know their project I don't talk about
what that is but basically that's that's
another thing I've got to today this is
all just feeling like a lot at once
basically so I've got to get my head
back in the zone and get to work
fortunately I'm very good at that
[Music]
so just have one of my meals of today
and rather calmly I decided that I'm
just gonna scrap the video that was
meant to come out this weekend because
it's already been done I think I think
it's unoriginal and I don't think it's
good enough I'm gonna rework that idea
basically still started to do with
general relativity I think there's an
interesting historical take on it the
first solution to the Einstein field
equations was derived by well no vacuum
solution was divided by Schwarz sports
child sparked stars never quite sure
special pronounce that name and it was
derived in the First World War
him he was serving on the Eastern Front
which is kind of amazing that you know
this really really high level maths and
he corresponding with Einstein and you
know this was all happening in the
middle of the most unimaginable conflict
if the thing I've always tried to
distinguish my channel against other
science channels is that I want to do
things with more of a personal narrative
that's in the sense of following my
personal narrative through my research
and getting people interested in science
through getting you know interested in
their might see the vlog and then they
watch the science videos from but also
in talking about science whenever I do
stuff outside of YouTube I always try
and link it to people's biographies
because I think it contextualizes what
people been working on and it makes
science seem more understandable it's
not some abstract concept it's just
emerged like a marble statue just
falling from the heavens I think that if
you focus on the individual it means
people makes people realize that okay I
can see what the full process was here I
can it's more relatable
so let's scrap that video yeah this is
the right decision I think it means more
work I'll be honest with you I've had a
really not very good day today
today's on those days we're all the
things that could go wrong all the
little tiny things like the Wi-Fi
dropping missing it was
you know like a render failing in your
software crushing abandoning and I did
even working on for a while all these
little things add up I'm like today has
been one of the worst days I've had for
a while it's just really ground me down
but knowing that I've got Jim to look
forward to the end of the day I get to
go weightlifting with Alex it's one of
those things you like okay just keep
pushing come on you can make it through
two for tonight like sport has such a
positive effect on your mental health it
really really does I say it all the time
but sometimes it does strike you it's
like I mean this could be anything to
look forward to but also like I know I'm
going to be physically active ya know
not a good day but one that you push
through and you just keep keep working
because you know if you're going through
hell keep going why would you stop
tomorrow's gonna be better tomorrow is
gonna be better we're gonna get more
done I'm gonna be that bit closer to
where I want to be
[Music]
I'm so glad you're done yeah me too
[Music]
of all the days to forget to bring a
towel with you in your shower
what is it had to be when there are work
went around bloody hell said Ron is late
in the day I have not blocked at all
today it's 9:00 in the evening and I
have basically tried to sort my life out
today so I've been like planning I will
in the future do a little thing on how I
structure my time once I figure out a
more efficient way of doing it for the
time being I'll just say that I was kind
of planning my time and a lot of today
was writing so as I've mentioned before
re restructuring this whole video to do
with it's not gonna be about fast and
light travel story about general
relativity but it's gonna be about black
holes and I have now basically got half
the script written the half that's
written is the introduction bit which is
kind of I find the most difficult thing
like trying to get people interested
immediately and then also the whole JJ
Abrams mystery box think of continuing
to provide things that were people want
answered
so that that bits done the newtonian
half is done now it's giving introducing
the relativity which is the stuff I've
been thinking about a lot so that should
be actually easier something that I have
been doing today is listening to this
album which is like there's a few
honours of music I like listening to and
I'm working to try and help me
concentrate one of them is kind of like
minimal electronic stuff the other half
is barak stuff and specifically I really
like baroque
keep keyboard music by that I mean not
like Casio DJ DJ I mean harpsichord
piano organ that kind of thing and this
is a banging new album it's on Spotify
and as you may be able to determine that
it's a world premiere recording even
though it's only from this year that's
because this is a manuscript that was
just found of some new stuff that Handel
wrote and it's it's really nice a boring
day in the vlog to be sure but a welcome
one basically I am trying to get head
down on this I feel like I'm late on
this video the science video is
following this will be much easier to
write this one is definitely much more
technical the one that I'm going to do
later is in case it doesn't come out
this week I won't say what it's about
but it's going to be easier to write
it's also going to be a bit more comedy
based love much more than normal anyway
and I know I have a very clear idea of
what that's gonna be so basically I've
got my head down and I'm working sorry
but you chose to follow the vlogger
somebody who has got two degrees like
this is this is kind of what I do I get
my head down when I want to do something
and I work I'll be more interesting
tomorrow I promise
[Music]
hello there I've been expecting you I
put the camera there so today is going
much better than yesterday and generally
this week I actually had a really good
night's sleep last night I went to bed
at like 10 so actually slept a decent
amount and that's translated it to be
writing today and I've nearly finished
off the script I've been super super
nitpicky with this one because it's
about relativity I think it's super
important to be exactly right there's a
lot of room when it comes to something
like relativity to say stuff that it's
like colloquially fine but
mathematically treacherous like there
are very specific meanings you have to
go through and relativity I think he's
kind of you get that more than most most
bits of physics it's kind of funny that
I tweeted earlier basically saying you
know if you wondered well I haven't
released anything this is why I remember
I was asked the Bristol talk about you
know do you feel obliged to your viewers
do you feel like you owe them stuff
because obviously I do and yet you have
to be careful about what you do what you
don't hang on the lighting makes me like
really ghostly okay oh that's a tripod
yeah yeah yeah like I do obviously oh my
my viewership a great deal the people
that subscribe to me in particularly
people and on patreon because reason I'm
in this position as I've said before and
the channel they're my boss but at the
same time it's not healthy to feel
obliged to upload and like kind of it's
the manipulation of your personal life
as but in the nature of videos that I do
manipulation of your personal life too
allow for work because effectively being
a youtuber and being a vlogger
specifically I've commoditized myself
and that is a kind of a weird thing a
weird position to be in because you end
up turning your life into the commodity
that you sell basically in your videos
and so at what point do you draw the
line between you living your life as you
determine it and living your life as
your viewers wish you to live it and
that will produce good content that will
satisfy your viewers it's a balancing
act but I've been very lucky to be such
a slow grower on YouTube up until
recently that I've had eight years to
try and find a balance and I feel like
I'm very much on the I'm going to live
my life the way I live it and my videos
will be a genuine representation of that
rather than my video my life being
controlled by the videos I want to make
because I think people value the organic
nature of that they value how genuine it
is I think people can spot very quickly
when something isn't genuine and it's
put on for the camera people's [ __ ]
actors are quite finely tuned and so
what people look for in a vlog is that
genuine aspect to it and as soon as you
stop having that and I don't watch this
videos but this is the kind of thing I
imagine live and pull does like people
watch it knowing that it's manufactured
but the whole point of this format to me
at least is the fact that it's not so
like me tweeting I'm sorry I haven't put
anything out it's more to do with the
science videos really I felt like if I
tweet apologizing for how boring my life
is that's that's kind of sad but like me
saying as a video producer you know
sorry I haven't produced a science video
in a little while that's because I'm
really trying on this one I'm putting an
awful lot of effort into this next
script if it was a blog it would be
different I think it's really this is a
minefield the whole the whole field of
being a person on YouTube has been
around for a few years but like I don't
think people's thought processes the way
people think about YouTube hasn't caught
up to that yet there's a really
interesting PhD to be done in like the
ethnography of YouTube why they'd
already do mine
all right that's a complete first draft
now I need to get that thing tightened
ducts it's too long I need to get it
filmed and ID don't like to get it
edited tomorrow if I have to edit it on
over the weekend that's not such a
problem it just means I'm delayed by a
week I actually have like a bit of a gap
between this next sponsor slot and the
the next one that's booked in so it's
not the end of the world if you know
this pushes things back a bit I think
it's worth I think the sponsors would
agree it's worth waiting for a better
product like a better video at the end
of the day as hopefully my subscribers
would which is the you know the more
important thing at the end of the day
but still that's good that's the first
draft it's good but it's just a bit long
I think not necessarily always a bad
thing now I'm gonna go to the gym but
because I showed you a lot of gym stuff
earlier this week I won't film it
oh good lighting holding the camera up
to the ceiling really really does one
this fee see you tomorrow
[Music]
okay
it is 11 o clock in the evening I'm
William Shatner and my Facebook is on
and we finally have a version of the
script which I'm happy with so trying to
kick some ass and do some filming Wow
I'm Way too excited about this this is a
script I've been wanting to make work
for a long time I'm just excited to
finally have a version that actually
works this is when this video completely
flops like I said before I normally do
behind the scenes stuff on my patreon
but I felt it'd be interesting to kind
of show you how I'm gonna be setting
this one up because the history of my
video I like the fact that doing a more
abstract mathematical content having a
more abstract background as a very
conscious decision because this isn't
gonna be a personal story it's going to
be about history and physics I want it
to have an impersonal background
otherwise it's kind of sending confusing
messages so we're in the green screen
using the green screen again gotta say
this is the studio I've had well if
anything I've had a proper studio
slaps office this is the most space I've
ever had to work with making videos and
oh my god does it make life easier
I might the first room that I would make
videos in I'm extra with probably half
the size of this room and I have to put
a bed in there so easy these days so the
most important thing when you are doing
a green screen video is lighting you've
got to make sure that it is as easy as
possible to pop yourself in the
background there's two ways of doing
that one making sure that the green
screen is properly lit also it make sure
it's at the proper height because that
definitely isn't and also I need to have
a rim light or hairlike basically sound
it's gonna pick out my edges so that
they don't bleed in to the green watch
caps and disillusions amazing video
about green screens if you want to know
more about this but yeah I only have so
many lights so this is a real challenge
so I'm gonna meet my homemade diffuser
out of the way that's gonna form a nice
big broad light source on me probably
got here tripod LED lights you're gonna
have you here to lighten Gentiles going
over there to lights and Gentiles what's
your job your jobs to be glory of thy
people Israel as you know this things
job is to hold the microphone it's got a
little pinchy pinchy boy at the end I
know how they got a pinchy boy it's got
a slight e boy you see you put the in
the slighty boy you clip in your long
boy then you've got a soundy boy I
should totally do a video making course
I know what I'm talking about I don't
think this is the right height yet I
ain't gonna be down to here but there's
not very much room at the top from this
height of camera especially if I move
closer forward that's not good enough
is it physics so I need to raise that up
so it can stand on mountains that's
better so normally in a lighting setup
you have three lights you also have a
facebook notification thing going off
every now and again so this is my
portable little light so hello like to
tell your story
oh my god oh we could put it up at a
high angle and it still kind of looks
like a horror film let's be fair like if
it's right in front I just found all of
this equipment I'm gonna make some
youtube but okay PewDiePie
okay so this is my third light but I'm
gonna be using this is one that I'll be
using to ping off the back of my me like
on my shoulders and hair and and also
illuminating hopefully the green-screen
in part most of the illumination will be
done by this slot parks please don't
break I only own one of pretty much
anything as soon as anything breaks I
need to buy it like a replacement
because I am poor yeah most of the
illumination that the Greens gonna be
done but this is the plan and then also
I'm going to be eliminated and mostly by
this with the actual light probably more
important but going through it so let's
try to set that up so I'm trying to go
up here is use the barn doors on this
for the actual Dory bits on the light to
illuminate me a little bit but mostly
the screen actually tell you what let's
put the softbox on the same time now
we're cooking on gas they've been had to
me throw the camera only yes smart good
good Simon smart Simon up above
for it's the circle that is not straight
so if I stand like here Wow okay so
that's illuminating isn't it quite
literally but cuz if I stand here that's
obviously way too much and I'm not
really getting very much from the barn
door from from this light in all
fairness
there's none what like to come in let's
do that that's much colder than this and
there's too much of it and I've got this
kind of weird two-tone faceoff poster
kind of thing going on so we need to
change what this light is doing fine as
you stand a little bit forward that's
something to do is to have two sets of
lights you have one set of light on that
and then as I'm the green screen that
one set of lights on me
I don't have enough lights for that so I
do that I do that people that know me
will tell you this is just the way I am
if I wasn't why would I say I am hmm
[Music]
okay so we're failing to generate an
even key to rethink this is an option
hey mr. blue okay I'm a little happy
with this now so I've got the big
homemade softbox here and I've got the
other proper softbox here you can see
that what did I bother
well that's doing is this softbox is
illuminating the green screen I've got
the hair light the extra added little
Sun and sauna which is illuminating
actually this will be interesting you
can see the difference this makes if I
turn it off back on this whole side is
just a little bit more evenly lit and
also it's doing a little bit of hair
light on me I can't stand it when hair
lights are too strong but it's just
enough to I think based on the small
viewfinder I have it's just enough to
kind of maybe pop and then in front of
me can't see it but we have a little
habit it'll have a little microphone so
this is basically setup the only other
thing I now need to add is my cheap as
chips tablet which I got for an absolute
bargain because it's not very good but I
only need it to run Google Docs so I
look at my script typical video like
this I'll pray take about two hours to
film what time is it
our Mother of God it's 11:30 I need to
get going
I'll see you after this assemblage of
outtakes
black holes are some of the most extreme
phenomena in the universe more extreme
than your mum was lying there just seems
to be some kind of mysterious action at
a distance
[Music]
she's my girl eyes she wants transport
that there was a SWAT shorts child
thought that there was a Schwarzschild
thought Schwartz to our four night UI
Danny Dyer my tablet's just died as I
suddenly just got much harder because my
phone is wank alright let's wrap that's
a wrap that's a wrap that's a wrap
on the first lot of camera stuff I now
need to do the zoom in stuff I'm gonna
take a break though my god take a break
that's right oh my god it's like Who I
am
why do I do this to myself I've gotta go
to the gym tomorrow morning I'll see you
in a few hours
[Music]
okay so it's literally like six hours
since I stopped filming last night the
end of the gym we're doing that we're
doing a morning session and it was cold
also the first thing you're taking in
the morning being pre-workout is a weird
experience my heart does not know what
it's doing right now also my fingers are
so cold that my very odd syndrome is
kicking in I'd have any blood in this
finger fight those weights well start
well start how you find in the regime so
far like going to the gym this much yes
I'm just going to have an annotated
diagram come off of the bits that hurt
on Alex's body right now okay so oh wow
this is really cool pretend that you're
a selfie stick so well I think unusual
things are cool um so uh the vlog is
finished I edited that today and the
Lighting's get increasingly worse let's
go back that way
and that is currently uploading however
because I live in the West Country the
internet isn't that best so I've got to
catch up so it's gonna be out tomorrow
morning which is like considering hang
on okay Oh considering that this is the
blog where I'm talking about the racism
scandal a texture
I don't like Steve Harrington even
though I don't think I'm saying anything
that is controversial
I think I'll articulated it in a way
that won't cause controversy can I have
a get worried because I hate personal
conflict I hate the idea of making
people upset especially considering that
I don't think I'm I believe or say
anything that is racist basically that's
why I worried I'm worried that people
are gonna take one look at the video
every night even watch the whole thing
but like you massive racist prick so I'm
a little I'm a little nervous about that
because I am NOT the most articulate
when it comes to issues like this so
fingers crossed like it's uploading it's
gonna go out tomorrow morning and I'm
gonna automate it but like it goes out
and I wake up in the morning in it's
like wait well let's see how that went
down but it's done and it's in the lap
of the gods now so I now need to move on
to edit the
black holes video that I shot the other
night except I did just get a text from
a friend I could stay and work on this
or I could for once go and have a drink
with some friends so today is Easter
Sunday which means it's chocolate
o'clock and the video has gone out this
morning I gave myself a lion basically
because I was editing I finished it off
relatively late last night I'm after the
pub and I just was like I'm just gonna
sleep through the response to this I
woke up and it seemingly people treat it
like any other vlog which is exactly
what I hoped would happen so who today
is gonna be fair bit of work actually um
now I haven't mentioned this yet but I
might way next week and I'll go taking
you with me
pixel girl and I are taking a holiday
just a couple of days off so she has a
break from her studies to Edinburgh so
I'm getting on a flight tomorrow but
then also on the weekend I'm uh I'm
going on a stag do not mine oh my god
more on that next week so today and
tomorrow before I get the flight which
is an evening I ideally want to get this
black holes video ready which I think
it's very possible and I also have a
podcast recording to do today because
the wiki cast that will go out in just
under a week so next week we're gonna
record today which is early in the
normal but because we had a gap should
be fine
hmmm alright so time to do the wiki cast
we have a guest today he might appear
behind me sometime soon we try to do the
guests episodes every 5 episodes and get
various people on because you know
there's only so much to down and I that
you can take as you have seen in the
exits in this block if you don't listen
to already it's just the two of us
talking so having other people in it it
allows us to kind of grow as a podcast
podcasts are very difficult things to
grow because it's not like YouTube with
our recommended videos in the sidebar or
anything like that so if you can hear
that beeping by the way that's the
discord for the people who listen to the
wiki cast it's quite difficult to grab
podcast so you either have to do it via
other media or through almost like on
YouTube old-school collapse so that's
one of the reasons we get guests in also
it does mix it up and you know get
people with actual talent in but this
week I was just recording a happy little
vlog I just broke my microphone
I'm so sorry granddad I've ruined your
table yeah yeah he stole this table from
Her Majesty's railway in the 50s it's
sunny LePage oh god I'm so sorry
favorite film zone Sally just like for
the class top five films not just not
just your favorite your top yes my top
favorites okay I think the ones that
come to mind okay so spotlight okay Fair
is an amazing film Eddie the Eagle okay
and now okay now yeah so join that
podcast I hit 120 thousand subscribers
which is pretty nifty I would say kind
nuts like if that was any other time in
the chest in my channel if I'd hit like
a multiple of 20,000 I've done like her
last time where that's happened so
quickly
this is nuts much like my hair right now
okay so it is currently just about ten
o'clock I am gonna call it a night here
I've been editing the looks like I'm
doing like go on get out of here I've
been editing the black hole video
basically doing the chroma key which I
actually earlier I'm doing an assembly
cut at this point this is getting the
clips in the right place and the
timeline not worrying about what the
hell is that
worrying about effects or anything like
that and I've also been doing a bit of
maths for a project that's coming up
I've been reminding myself of some of
the basics it's amazing how much you
forget this is stuff I was like my bread
and butter for so long but doing a pass
paper for a for an exam and was just
like yeah okay
I remember now like it's coming back I'm
pretty wiped so I'm gonna get an early
night and tomorrow for me next episode
for you it's gonna be me going off to
Edinburgh with pixel go I'm gonna
hopefully finish this video off tomorrow
I want to get up relatively early and
really hit it hard I've also got the gym
tomorrow without axe but yeah next week
is gonna be fun because I realized it's
been three episodes of me basically
being here yes I've been to Exeter and
all that and it's snowed and it's all
with all that fun but basically every
week from now something interesting is
happening I'm either going away
somewhere or something interesting is
happening here next weeks it's gonna be
a very interesting vlog because I'm
gonna be a pixel go the entire time so
well in Edinburgh and then I get like
one day here to finish the wiki cast and
then I'm back off for this as yet
mystery stag do its I'm really looking
forward to it that's all I'll say
so yeah that's it for this episode I
hope you enjoyed it do give the episode
of like if you enjoyed it give it a
share if you like the idea of other
people seeing these videos and comment
with what you enjoyed and also what you
didn't enjoy this is meant to be a
two-way feedback that's the whole thing
about YouTube is it's a conversation so
I want to hear your thoughts on the
vlogs and how they're going so far and
yeah I hope you stick around for the
next episode when maybe I work out what
the hell I'm supposed to do for this PHT
thank you for watching
[Music]
[Music]